und jetzt ist endlich mal Leben in der
alten Bude die deutsche
Parteienlandschaft wird komplett auf
links gedreht oder auf rechts je nachdem
wie es läuft jedenfalls Meldung der
Woche Wagenknecht macht Ernst ja am
Montag hat sie es vorgestellt dass
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht geiler Name
denn da steckt ja schon das komplette
Programm mit drin ne kurz im Gespräch
waren alternativ m SED Saras endgeile
deutschlandpartei und äh
dsfip die dem seine Frau ihre
Partei ja aber ich schon irre oder ist
das Wahnsinn eine Partei die es noch gar
nicht gibt holt top umfrageerte müssen
die anderen Parteien schon viel falsch
gemacht haben die sara ist halt ein ja
ein mediengeschöpf hat man auch bei der
PK am Montag gesehen riesen Medienzirkus
als würde Olaf Scholz seine Verlobung
mit Taylor Swift bekannt geben obwohl
dann kä wahrsinlich
weniger dieeren Bühne kannte niemand
oder fast niemand aber klar Sarah
Wagenknecht umgibt sich nur mit
parteizwergen mit mit Minions je kleiner
die anderen desto mehr Aufmerksamkeit
für sie zehn Abgeordnete verlassen die
Linkspartei behalten aber ihre Mandate
logisch ist ja logisch mal schöne Büros
Fahrdienst der Jägerschnitzel Donnerstag
in der Bundestagskantine da verzichtest
du doch nicht drauf ne Wagenknecht hat
jedenfalls keine skupel das Mandat zu
behalten denn 98% der linken Wähler
haben bei der letzten Wahl die Partei ja
nur wegen ihr gewählt und das weiß ich
so genau weil die ihr alle geschrieben
haben da habe ich ganz viele Mails von
Menschen bekommen die mir geschrieben
haben also wenn sie ihr Mandat
zurückgeben dann will ich auch meine
Stimme zurück dann möchte ich auch meine
Stimme zurück das haben mir so viele
Menschen gesagt das sagen mir auch viele
Menschen haben mir ganz viele Menschen
geschrieben sehr sehr vielen Menschen
Menschen die mir geschrieben haben SAR
Wagenknecht
furchtbar furchtbar sympathisch ja da
wurde doch garantiert wieder geschnitten
bei der Oma Lügen Presse übrigens dass
die Linkspartei überhaupt im Bundestag
sitzt verdankt sie nur den drei
Direktmandaten der Genossen Gesi Lösch
und Pellmann aber das sind Details für
sowas interessiert sich eine Wagenknecht
nicht so was will die
wagenknechtpartei höhere Steuern für
Superreiche und mehr Geld für ich
zitiere sie die fleißigen die fleißigen
das fordert die Frau mit den enormen
vielzeit im Bundestag wunderbar dazu
eine Prise Migration begrenzen plus ein
Teelöffel bedrohte Meinungsfreiheit ja
man darf ja nichts mehr sagen und ich
find es toll dass Deutschlands
beliebtester Talkshow Gast das mal
anprangert dafür ist sie aber sehr
nachsichtig mit echten Autokratien und
fordert z.B das Ende sämtlicher
Sanktionen eine Öffnung einer großen
Gasleitung ob nordstream 1 oder
nordstream 2 und am besten natürlich
beide würde die Situation auf einen
Schlag entspannen
ah nichts ist so entspannt wie eine
offene Gasleitung natürlich ja und keine
Missverständnisse ich behaupte nicht
dass Putin sie bezahlt ich find es nur
unverschämtit dass sie ihr nichts
bezahlt ja nächstes Jahr will
Wagenknecht bei der Europawahl antreten
und einen ersten Wahlspots gibt's
tatsächlich auch schon ind dem erfährt
man endlich wie schlecht es Deutschland
wirklich geht wussten sie z.B dass wir
hier alle in Schwarz-Weiß Leben unser
Land ist in keiner guten Verfassung seit
Jahren wird an den Wünschen der Mehrheit
vorbeiegiert statt Leistung zu belohnen
wurde von den fleißigen zu den oberen
10.000 umverteilt die Regierung wirkt
planlos und in vielen Fragen schlicht
inkompetent es braucht verlässliche
Politiker die sich diesen Zielen
verpflichtet fühlen heilige Sara erlöse
uns aber warum fassen sich die Bürger in
ihrem Spot alle ständig an Kop haben sie
das gesehen hier reaction Video der
ersten die ihn bei Youtube gesehen haben
er hat gerade erst mit dem Video
angefangen er ist schon fertig damit und
ihn müsste man anzeigen weil er es mit
seinem armen Hund geguckt hat
Tierquälerei aber sehen wir vielleicht
auch mal die Chance meine Damen und
Herren die wagenknechtpartei bringt
Bewegung in den Politikbetrieb und
wissen Sie was das allertollste ist seit
dieser Woche ist die AFD ganz offiziell
Moment
altpartei
[Applaus]
schiße ja die Tröte ist aus dem ZF
Fundus ja altpartei herzlichen
Glückwunsch AFD voll lame ja angeblich
können sich 30% der afdwähler zumindest
vorstellen zu Wagenknecht überzulaufen
der alte Traum endlich recht sein ohne
recht zu sein es gibt eine Alternative
zur Alternative ich wette den geht der
Stift es gibt eine Partei für gesunden
Menschenverstand das ist die AFD also
von daher ist es ein weiterer
politischer Mitbewerber aber ich habe
jetzt keine angstperlen auf der
Stirn keine angstperlen sagt der Mann
der die Polizei ruft wenn ihn eine Biene
sticht ja vielleicht schwächt
Wagenknecht die AFD vielleicht auch
nicht dann haben wir einfach eine
weitere nicht bündnisfähige meckerptei
in den Parlamenten sitzen AFD und
bündnisara Wagenknecht behaupten beide
für die sogenannten normalen Menschen zu
kämpfen sagen die ständig wir arbeiten
für die normalen und natürlich bestimmen
Sie was normales und was nicht dafür ist
aber muss ich sagen der Fanshop der
neuen Partei sehr schön geworden der Sar
Shop da verkauft sie z.B ihren eigenen
Eistee der heißt
Kommunist Geschmacksrichtung Mango
Borscht ihr eigenes Fertiggericht die
Pizza vier Wahlversprechen mit extra
viel populistischem Käse und natürlich
für alle bald Arbeitslosen Politiker der
zerstörten Linkspartei die original
winke Sara winke
winke ja und das scheint ihr tatsächlich
völlig schnurz zu sein was aus denen
jetzt wird den zurückgelassenen die sie
quasi ausgesetzt hat an der
autobahnraschette des Lebens wenn die SA
wagenkn nicht geht dann sind sind wir
als LINKE auf einem Niveau dass äh
äh der wieer Tierschutzverein
ist ja schön wär es schön wär es der
Tierschutzbund hat rund 800.000
Mitglieder die Linkspartei gerade mal 54
000 Tendenz fallt ihretwen ja das wird
eine bittere Zeit für die Linkspartei
man braucht mindestens 37 Abgeordnete
für den Fraktionsstatus im Bundestag es
gehen aber zehn weg dann gilt man nur
noch als sogenannte Gruppe ist nicht
schön wir Schalen mal live zu Valerie
nihaus Abgeordnete der originall
Linkspartei von nihaus wie schmutzig
wird die Scheidung ach hören sie bloß
auf wir müssen uns noch wochenlang Büros
Teilen mit den blöden wagenknechten hier
guck mal wie die aussieht die zieht sich
schon so an wie Sara die Haare wie Sarah
das ist keine Partei das ist eine Sekte
ich nenne sie die Sara
fisten guck mal wie die guckt guck mal
wie die guckt toxisch deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier erstmal so eine provisorische
bürogrenze gebaut damit die alte nicht
an meine Sachen geht apropos ist das
etwa meine
Espressomaschine eine
Frechheit steinzeitkommunisten die
glauben nicht an
Eigentum trotzdem Herr welke ich bin
froh dass die Trennung durch ist was wir
gelitten haben in den letzten Jahren
unter dem Sara Regime ja ich darf Sie
ganz herzlich begrüßen Bernt das ist die
Pressekonferenz der Fraktion also ich
begrüße Sie auch ganz
herzlich
ja also seit dem Tag weint sich der Bern
jede Nacht im Schlaf verstehe aber ist
es denn wirklich so schlimm nur noch
Gruppe zu sein ach nö also wenn es einem
als angeblich linke scheißegal ist dass
über 100 franktionsmitarbeiter ihren Job
verlieren dann nicht diese Spalter
zerstören die Linkspartei und sagen
hinterher eiskalt wichtig ist uns zu
betonen dass wir ohne Groll gehen und
wir nehmen trotz aller Schwierigkeiten
auch viele gute Erinnerungen an unsere
Zeit in der Linken mit ihr nimmt vor
allem sehr viele gute Wähler mit ihr
Verräter wegen denen kriegen wir alle
weniger Geld als Fraktion gibt's fast
eine halbe Million im Monat für die
parlamentarische Arbeit komplett futsch
vielen Dank auch uns wird alles genommen
gestern haben sie meinen Bionade
Kühlschrank abgeholt wissen Sie was ich
jetzt auf muss
riverola okay das ist schlimm zugeben
andererseit in der ordnung des
Bundestages steht ja gar nicht drin
welche rechte Gruppen haben wer weiß
vielleicht erlauben euch die richtigen
Parteien ja noch kleine Anfragen zu
stellen oder so es ist so erniedrigend
wie man behandelt wird als Gruppe auch
in der Bundestagskantine nicht das ist
eine totale
Zweiklassengesellschaft die Fraktionen
kriegen richtig gutes Zeug und wir als
Gruppe na
ja so aber mir reicht's jetzt ich schaff
hier Fakten und lass richtige Mauer
durchs Büro bauen wie früher ja deine
Chefin findet doch die DDR so geil die
könnt er jetzt zurück haben so weißt du
was den
Stacheldraht den hau ich selber rein
Schnauze voll hier valerine nehaus
vielen
Dank so meine Damen und Herren
sie werden es mitbekommen haben wir
haben uns zuletzt in dieser Sendung beim
Thema naheosten kaum beteiligt mangels
echter Expertise aber inzwischen geht's
ja längst auch um das was hier bei uns
passiert dass jüdische Eltern ihre
Kinder aus Angst nicht zur Schule
schicken dass Häuser mit Davidsternen
markiert werden oder dass es regelrecht
gefährlich ist mit Kipper durch Berlin
zu laufen das ist einfach nur furchtbar
und beschämend für uns alle klammern wir
uns also heute an das bisschen was
gerade Hoffnung macht z.B das hier
Vertreter von vier muslimischen
Verbänden besuchen letzten Montag die
Synagoge in Köln und sprechen klare
Worte zum hamasterror heute gab es den
Gegenbesuch in einer Bochumer Moschee
oder hier Augsburg ein Jugendlicher holt
vor dem rathus die israelische Flagge
vom Mast wir sie anzünden und dann hey
das wird nicht angefackelt ich B dass du
eine andere Meinung hast aber es wird
nicht angefackelt wirklich gib die Fahne
her und dann ab auf die Stille
Treppe ich feier diese Frau ich feier
die genauso wie die Fans von Chemie
Leipzig und Eintracht Frankfurt die eine
bedrohte jüdische Bar beschützt haben
Mainz 05 hat einen Spieler wegen eines
geteilten antisemitischen Post
freigestellt auch der FC Bayern hat in
einem ganz ähnlichen Fall knallhart Spa
Spaß Moral beim FC Bayern nein das war
natürlich nur ein Witz nein nein für den
Spieler masrawii gab es bei den Bayern
natürlich gar keine Konsequenzen die
Strafe war du spielst Champions League
Freundchen anfangs das wird Lehre sein
warte mal wer ruft denn jetzt an jetzt
pass mal auf du Vogel warum spielt
einmraui weiter beim FC Bayern obwohl er
so eine Scheiße postet ja warum wohl
weil sich der Goretzka verletzt hat und
der Leimer wieder von der zwe auf die
sech muss dann fehlt uns aber einer
hinten in der Viererkette können Sie
noch bis Vier zählen Herr welke können
Sie zählen was kann ich habe ich mir
gedacht dass einer wie sie mal
fußballmoderator war das ist eine
Schande für Deutschland auf wiederhör
wir warum stellt ihr den durch da hatten
wir drüber gesprochen den höhnis nie
durchstellen gibt's doch gar nicht aber
gut wir haben eh andere Probleme
jenseits von viereraketten große
Probleme in der Hauptstadt z.B oder
konkret in Berlin Neuköln wo es
inzwischen mehrmals zu gefechtsähnlichen
Szenen zwischen Polizei und
Demonstranten gekommen ist inklusive
Steine schmeißen und
judenhassparolen Antisemitismus in
wohlgemerkt bestimmten muslimischen
Communities da hatte man naiverweise
gedacht wenn das Existenzrecht Israels
deutsche staatsreson ist dann schnappt
man das schon irgendwie auf wenn man
hier aufwächst klappt leider nicht bei
jedem wir diskutieren also schon zurecht
über importierten Antisemitismus dürfen
aber auch den heimischen nicht vergessen
ja auch im eher linken oder wen Milieu
gibt's heute Antisemiten bzw sorry
antisemittinnen natürlich ja Fridays for
future international verbreitet z.B
inzwischen lupenreine hamaspropaganda ja
auch sie und wirft Israel einen Genozid
vor deutsche Bildungsbürger sagen völlig
selbstverständlich setze wie
gerade wurde ein Transparent
beschlagnahmt weil dort drauf steht dass
Palästina sich befreien wird vom
Mittelmeer bis zum Jordan diese paroleß
das für Israel Existenzrecht Israels z.B
wir glauben nicht dass es so etw dass
wir ein Existenzrecht für Staaten und
vor allem nicht für Kolonialregime und
apartheitregime gibt oh Gott ein
deutscher erklärt die Nachfahren der
Holocaust Überlebenden zu Kolonialisten
wenn das meiner wä ich würde die noch in
dem Alter durch die Babyklappe stopfen
wirklich falls er durchpasst und und nur
fürs Protokoll natürlich ist auch die
Meinungsfreiheit ein hohes Gut in diesem
Land friedlicher Protest gegen die
israelische Besatzungspolitik oder die
Abriegelung von Gaza muss möglich sein
aber das macht die Hamas ja nicht zu
einer Befreiungsbewegung das ist eine
völlig enthemmte Terrortruppe die Opfer
in der eigenen Zivilbevölkerung fest mit
einplant oder wie Jannis warufakis
linker posterby der griechischen
Finanzkrise
sagt try very hard to extract people
like
DM die Leute die wollen dass ich die
Angriffe der hamaskerer verurteile
werden das nie zu hören
kriegen ja jamas bzw waru fick dich für
was würdest du denn diese schlechter
verurteilen oder war das kranke
Interview jetzt auch schon wieder Kunst
wie damals mit dem Stinkefinger und Jan
bömermann steckt dahinter wohl eher
nicht schade es ist eine wahnsinnig
aufgeheizte Stimmung in der vor allem
auf Social Media eine ganze Flut von
Fake News und Propaganda verbreitet wird
vielen Dank Elon Musk vielen Dank KI
auch deshalb halten sich heute so viele
für
nahostexperten und langweilen ihre
Facebook Follower mit halbgarn Vorträgen
über das Westjordanland klug scheißen
ist halt wahnsinnig Deutsch wir scheißen
wahnsinnig gerne klug vor allem in den
letzten Jahren man darf nicht vergessen
wir sind ja sowieso immer 83 Millionen
Bundestrainer ach m Nagels du le l do
nicht Standard schießen
kann dann plötzlich waren wir alle was
labert der es gibt nur einen guten
Impfstoff den aus Russland der trotzem
kann nichts und jetzt sind die möchte
gern auskenn haltener ostexperte die
Amerikaner müssten viel mehr Druck
machen auf Hamas und Israel dieser Joe
Biden kann
nichtich es gibt so viele Deutsche die
Wissen tatsächlich alles also sagen wir
die wissen fast
alles wo kommen die Tabs
rein aber was überhaupt Deutschlands
Rolle in dieser neuen immer
gefährlicheren Welt na was wohl wir sind
die guten wie immer was sonst
tatsächlich hat jetzt sogar jede
deutsche Botschaft einen eigenen
Beauftragten für Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik in Doha Katar ist das Klaus
von Wagner der sich dabei aber
offensichtlich nicht wirklich kaputt
macht
ne weil Werte geleitet geht hier ja gar
nicht welche Werte soll ich bei den
Kataris durchsetzen abhängig von denen
nicht umgekehrt also meistens sitze ich
jetzt hier oben auf dem Dach zwischen
paar Bierchen und nenne es Leberwerte
geleitete
Außenpolitik
aha nun ist aber ja Katar zusammen mit
dem Iran der größte Finanzier der Hamers
Terroristen
ja es ist nicht schön aber ich meine was
soll man machen nicht nur weil ab 2026
die großen Gaslieferung von hier kommen
ne die katari sind auch noch
Großaktionäre bei der Deutschen Bank
Siemens VW abergut wir gehören den quasi
und wenn der EM uns besucht wie neulich
fragst sich keine Sekunde wer in dem
Bild der Chabo ist und wer der Babo na
kleiner was macht der ganze Bums den ich
mir hier gekauft habe klar es mit der
Hamas ist unschön auch fürs deutsche
Image da könnten irgendwann sogar Klagen
vor US-Gerichten drohen aber wichtig ist
ja nur dass sich Konzerne mit Kataris im
Aufsichtsrat jetzt mal eindeutig
verhalten wie reagiert Volkswagen nun
der Konzern wagt öffentlich keine Kritik
warum Qatar öffentlich zu kritisieren
bringe nichts man wolle die Fronten
nicht verhärten in diesem Jahr sind 1,4
Milliarden Euro Dividende in das Emirat
geflossen ja komm das geht ja jetzt
nicht alles an die Hamas ne wie schön
die Hamas Führung sitzt da in Doha in
klimatisierten Büros und befiehlt von da
aus Terroranschläge das können wir doch
nicht ignorieren sein sie froh dass wir
die Hamas nicht mehr direkt
unterstützen jetzt schauen sie ne ja die
Hamas ist nämlich ein Ableger der
Muslimbrüderschaft und die Muslimbrüder
wurden bei ihrer Gründung in den 30er
Jahren kräftig gefördert von richtig den
deutschen Nazis und die haben ien
Judenhass auch im gesamten Nahen Osten
verbreitet auf Arabisch toller Service
mit dem nazipropagandasender hier Radio
cesen da gab's mal eine richtig gute
Folge hier von der dieser Sendung kennt
die ansalt schon mal gehört die
Anstalt ja
richtig gute Satiere die geh auch mal in
die Tiefe ja nicht so wie andere ich sag
mal mehr kommedy orientierte Shows so ne
ich habe mal hier ein Sketch von denen
verlinkt falls sie gucken wollen ja ist
gut
jetzt gibt's doch gar nicht aber was
bleibt denn dann noch von dem ganzen
Werte Dingsbums Dividenden aus
Deutschland landen in Qatar dass unter
anderem die hamasverwaltung in Gaza
finanziert und dann sagt unser Kanzler
wer eine Terrororganisation wie die
Hamas unterstützt der macht sich
strafbar die Strafverfolgungsbehörden
von Bund und Ländern werden jeden der so
etwas tut zur Rechenschaft
ziehen rige Vorstellung Olaf schickt das
SEK in die Vorstandsetage von Volkswagen
welke werd mal erwachsen Deutschland ist
ja auch immer noch Irans wichtigsteer
Handelspartner in EU wir kaufen Gas aus
Aserbaidschan und wenn der Diktator über
100.000 Armenier verjagt machen wir
nichts außer dummes Gesicht komm mal
runter von deinem hohen Ross dein ZDF
wir garantiert auch bald von Qatar
gekauft tja genau das wüsste ich aber
wir sind immer noch ein öffentlich
rechtlicher
Sender oh
ein als schich verkleideter
Kameramann okay kulturelle Aneignung ich
hör dir trapsen ja hät z.B in der
Anstalt nicht gegeben ich sag's ja nur
ja ach leck mich Klaus von Wagner vielen
Dank komm müssen Strom sparen mach die
Kamera aus Jürgen heute machen wir
asmr
bissnelke arschkrampe Firle Fan
abonniert den Kanal für die nächsten
Schimpfwörter sonst setzt es
was